been a little while since we spoke
it was around extraction time i mean i
loved the movie
and i loved the action that you did in
it but there was no way of knowing how
huge that movie was going to be on
netflix yeah i mean
when we made the movie we were just
trying as i think everyone does
to make a movie that we believed in and
that we felt would be
you know exciting and entertaining to
audiences and we thought we had a pretty
a decent movie on our hands and i still
think that but the response
that we've gotten from audiences all
over the world
during the release and still was
overwhelmingly positive and could never
have expected it to be
um i guess so well received in such a
short amount of time
yeah what was it like because you can
tell
you know netflix is usually never going
to release like exact numbers although
that's basically the number one movie on
netflix
um i think in history uh but
how quickly how quickly was like scott
stuber or someone from netflix calling
you
after a premiere just say hey we need to
sit down and talk about
doing another one uh well truthfully
the there was talk of doing another one
before we even finished shooting the
first one
um you know so there was always that
rumble you know when we were making the
movie we never we didn't take that
seriously we were trying to focus on
making the best single movie possible
but there were rumblings of doing
another one you know what whether the
story goes forward or backwards they
were trying to figure that out but
they kept us netflix has a very
interesting process they kind of you
know
certain periods during after the release
date you know certain days they check in
with you
and you know they were very uh excited
but also
you know trying as we were to just uh
not get too overzealous with prediction
of numbers
but they were like you know kind of
eyebrow raising numbers of like this
could really go
you know really far really fast and then
it did
and that kind of i think solidified the
start of the the um you know writing the
next one which joe russo was doing
at this moment yeah joe told me that he
was hard at work writing the screenplay
and he also told me that they were that
you guys are aiming to shoot
in the fall of this year uh obviously if
things go well
is that still the case still the case
you know
uh covet pending that's kind of
everyone's
little caveats but we're we're moving
forward on it as if we're
you know we'll be shooting in the fall
we're still you know day um
sorry joe is still finalizing the script
we're all excited to read you know i've
read different
iterations but excited to read what he
turns in and
um yeah we're all looking forward to
getting getting back in the saddle and
hopefully bringing
another action-packed fun adventure in
the extraction universe
the the thing that i'm curious about
with you is uh
the action is so awesome in extraction
and the way you use
camera to tell the story to to you know
to
to make these action set pieces so good
have you
how early on like right now for example
are you already thinking
how are we going to raise the bar what
are we going to do in the sequel
that we haven't done already
we talked about that extensively and you
know truthfully steve i'm always
i walk around you know my my house or
walk around town looking for ways to do
something fun or different with action i
kind of think
as if there's you know a camera behind
my eyes all the time like what would be
an interesting way to capture this oh
that'd be cool
so i'm always cataloging and trying to
think of different fun ways to capture
action and different action set pieces
that would be great so
joe and i talked a lot about that
pitched some ideas bounced them around
and you know we're i'm just excited to
the challenge because yeah it is that is
the
the difficult thing right but the beauty
of all these different great action
films
is they uh challenge filmmakers and
myself included to
raise the bar like how are we going to
raise the bar
when there's you know a lot of movies
even since extraction a lot of movies
have come out and
been pushing the envelope and we gotta
we gotta keep push back
you know we gotta just keep elevating
the level of action i talked to chad a
lot about the john wick series
and he's always like you know each of
these movies and john wick
uh has really done stuff and i think
he's both intimidated by
and excited by what they get to do in
john wick
um i'm curious with joe and the writing
of this
the sequel screenplay or prequel
whatever it ends up being i know you're
not going to tell me
um i'm curious how early on is he
telling you
what he's thinking about and you sort of
already talking to him about the action
and how much do you sort of have to wait
until the whole thing is figured out
before you can start you know
breaking it down it's
a it's a process it's a happy medium
early on
we talked a lot about set pieces that he
wanted to design
the story around basically so we know
there's certain
certain places that we want to go
certain things that we want to happen
in there and then you know what he has
been doing over the past months is
weaving a story in and around those
action set pieces that
then once you know once the script comes
in and we look at him then
you know he's he's going to have
exciting his job is to have an exciting
read
and to really hook those who are going
to you know put up money for the movie
or
you know actors who want to join the
movie that's the number one goal of the
screenwriter is to hook the reader
and get people interested so he's gonna
have super exciting action which he
always does
i'm excited to read it but then the next
step would be to get a hold of the
script and go in there in detail and say
okay
for example this uh you know set piece
takes place in a you know uh
whatever an african um you know market
or
you know a prison cell or wherever it is
that you might find yourself
how do we take the specifics of that and
make the action interesting related to
character reveal things about the
character push
this character you know whoever it is in
ways maybe they haven't been pushed
before
before to have you know illicit
responses maybe you haven't seen before
and so that that's where i know the fun
for me begins is once you get the
template of the script
and the story and the beats all the
beats that happened that tell the story
how do we
enhance that with the action and really
try to take the storytelling to the next
level
through physical action when the movie
is such a hit for netflix
um and the whole world watches how does
that
impact for example the you talking to
them about budget
the first movie was made at a price and
i'm curious if they're thinking okay
well this is a huge hit
do you need more money to make the
sequel like
bigger or like you know what i mean how
does that negotiation work
yeah well i think in general the the
main thing you got to remember is it's
it's
show business so in business you know if
you got to keep your costs down so that
your profits are high right so that
no one is is rushing out to the bank and
say let's triple the cost
because it was you know because we can
everyone's going to want to keep the
the budget down now what the the benefit
of having a successful movie
you know is at least in the past has
been you know
say we were successful before we want a
little bit something extra here
because we want to make it even better
and now you have a little bit of
leverage saying
you know we did this in the past we're
asking for something
and you know we delivered before and you
you're the trust
that you will deliver again is a little
higher so in general they'll be willing
to
stretch a little bit more but again
everyone's trying to you know
trying to keep the margins you know you
know it's in the black so that you guys
are making making money
uh joe talks about how he's thinking
about everything as like an extraction
universe how there could be a different
movie focusing on another character
how it sort of ties in obviously there's
only one
of you um so how much are you
looking at these extraction sequels or
spin-offs or whatever it might be
um and how many of these things do you
want to take on you know or is it just
like
you know what i mean how is that sort of
working
i think joe and anthony that whole agbo
team are brilliant in that
kind of building upon the marvel
universe
aspect where a lot of these films
connect and
you know intersect in their journeys
with characters they're kind of
building on that model in this world
with calling in the extraction universe
and there is a lot of opportunity to
follow characters that people have
shown an affinity for and sounds like
they want to know more about
so my personal involvement i mean i
would love to
be as involved as possible but i i also
don't want to be
greedy there's a lot of other super
talented filmmakers out there who
would have very unique visions who are
going to bring something new and fresh
to the franchise that i would be excited
to see
as a fan you know i would you know
hopefully we get to do the second one
all of us the kind of the same team and
really establish the franchise if you
will and then from there
i would love to see as a fan of cinema
what other young directors
who can again push the level of action i
would love for people to
you know as much as it's fun for people
to appreciate extraction
maybe be in a movie about you know saji
or obi or
or nick they can be like that's what
people are talking about now that
someone did something so incredible
that this is now the standard that i as
a filmmaker and another you know another
film have to
try and keep you know climbing the
ladder to to
give audiences the best kind of
entertainment we can
i would imagine after the success of the
first film it's going to be a hell of a
lot easier
to get whoever the hell you want in the
sequel have you already started thinking
in your in your mind
i really want such and such to be in
this movie
oh i mean yes and no because the the the
big thing
for me is always about story and
character and then whatever you know
once we dive in and you know joe is
finished with the script and we get
a full picture of who who that's going
to be and where
then you know i've got a catalog of
those who i would love to work with
from both an acting standpoint and an
action standpoint just some
you know fresh faces then we'll take
we'll take the script take that catalog
of
actors would like to work with and try
to as best we can fit them together and
hopefully
have a new dynamic cast you must have
done a lot of meetings
and met a lot of people that maybe you
hadn't met because all of a sudden
you delivered on this movie so can you
sort of talk about maybe
um other other things that you're
developing right now that
are not extraction sequels or you know
prequels
um that you are currently you know
working on
indeed i mean that you know i'm first
and foremost the storyteller
and the filmmaker and as you know as um
successful as extraction was and as as
much as that got me in the room so to
speak with other with other people
i'm um you know i'm not
just just solely relying on the
extraction universe to go through i want
to be as involved as possible but i've
got a lot of
story ideas of my own that i've been
developing the this time
off in during covet i've spent a lot of
time writing with my writing partner
fernando chen
so we're developing you know we've got a
tv show that we're working with
producers on
pitching and we've got a feature that
we've adapted and we've got another
you know story that we're working on as
well as other scripts that have come in
the doors have been opened because of
extraction and
gotten some really great scripts that
we're trying to develop so there are
there are many
irons in the fire so to speak um or to
use the language of jerusalem a lot of
frogs lined up on the starting line so
we'll see which one
jumps jumps in the right direction first
got it so you think the next time you're
directing a feature
is extraction in the fall
hard to say like i'd like it to be like
that's that's been you know that would
if i had my druthers that would be what
i'd be doing but you know
it all depends right like the the hard
part right now
is truthfully the the covet of it all
and with the scale and scope
that we're trying to encompass with this
story
that may put limitations on the
execution of that
and so we have to decide like is it do
you change the story to make it happen
when you want it happen or do you
you know kind of say hey this is a big
enough grand enough story that we want
to wait until we can do this safely
and inclusively of all the different you
know places we want to travel so it's
it's hard to say that would be
that's the plan but we have to be
flexible